ich frag mich was er sich hier anguckt
gerade allem ein name zu bekommen wir
heute zu einer neuen ausgabe des
formates luca reagiert auf komische
webseiten den besten format auf youtube
[Applaus]
lange gewöhnt lange nicht mehr
hochgeladen
die website 0 er auf seinem kanal da
geht es darum dass wir uns hier gerade
in einem zug befinden wir fahren in
einen tunnel rhein befinden uns jetzt in
einem wald fahren durch einen weiteren
sohn durch einen weiteren tunnel wieder
durch einen weiteren tunnel und sind
wieder in der schneelandschaft nur erst
quasi eine website wo einfach nur
sonnenschein
wir klicken einfach mal auf next und den
als nächste website eine kartoffel
beziehungsweise eine zitrone die tanz
das ist ja das ist super cool als
nächstes haben wir hier einen ladebalken
und jetzt eine anime
ja es ist das sehr interessantes video
hier im zweifel hier beinhaltet einen
typen der kurz und jetzt steht er dort
wieder dein mund abgewischt und er kommt
wieder
frag mich was er sich hier anguckt
gerade eigentlich nur videopreis
vielleicht irgendwann ich hoffe wir
kriegen mal wieder auf random schauen
uns die nächste website an und sehen ein
kopf der sich im kreis dreht
ja
das prinzip dieser website
die quasi einfach daraus komische video
und aneinandergereiht werden
das heißt er mir beispielsweise anime
video wo leute anime kämpfen oder wieder
auf rennen blicken sehen wir schon wir
haben das ist das denn
ich glaube das soll sollen pokemon
darstellen wie ihr beispielsweise heißt
es normal wenn diese
falls ich glaube dass die sollen hydro
wie darstellen halt voll riegel und in
die wir ich bin mir aber nicht so ganz
sicher weil was macht er überhaupt mit
seinem fuß da man hier klicken wieder
auf random und haben als nächste website
finger die in verschiedene richtungen
zeigen das liegt uns auch nicht so sehr
wie kriegen wir auch wenn ihm eine
fliege die rumliegt vielleicht haben wir
das mal irgendwie nur dumm rum
ja
nicht einfach nur darum wo mein gott
eine katze oder irgendein anderes ding
was auf einer straße den berg runter
fährt dabei ein pianist der gegen die
leitplanke stefan hat gedauert hat man
passiert
die wiederholt dass die ganze zeit nur
als nächstes haben wir einen falschen
party hard und leute die auf der straße
stehen und jetzt meine damen und herren
ich frage mich wozu er einfach so krass
ab geht gerade zwei süße anime mädchen
die mit ihrer trompete in einem zimmer
spielen das war es auch schon wieder das
ist das ist tatsächlich wieder alles
gewesen
die fehle gerade hätte ich lieber nicht
rein parken dürfen ich hab was sagt
wahrscheinlich nur mein gesicht gesehen
dass heute wieder ab 18 gewesen
berlinicke eine anime frau die ihren
popo schüttelt das wird eigentlich so
die perfekte beschreibung für diese
website grundsätzlich 6 an
warum 6 anja mehr eine person die einen
wert rutter feld und währenddessen eine
discokugel die mega abgeht leute die um
den pool umlaufen mit der überschrift
der pool ist heute geschlossen
irgendwelche szenen auf dem fortschritt
weil jemand handgranaten in der hand hat
und den leuten irgendwas zuruf und auf
jeden fall übels ab geht die ganze zeit
was soll das sein
hey ich weiß nicht ob das ein cockpit
oder was das überhaupt darstellen soll
ja mir eine kursstütze einblendung
beklaut opened up und als up and i came
from heaven meine damen und herren dr
das ist das mit sabine alltag eine
person mit einem papagei auf der
schulter
er überspielt konsole meckert irgendwen
an rastet aus guckt in die kamera
sportart und stellt wahrscheinlich
irgendwie nach stimmen
da fragen uns natürlich jetzt alle den
hätte diese person hier gerade
nachstellen können wir diesen komischen
bewegungen
[Musik]
ja ich weiß
sandel machen etwa fünf gramm videos auf
dieser website und danach will ich das
video auch beenden also das erste ja
cool irgendwelche komischen leuten die
auf dem kinderspielplatz zum tanzen als
nächstes haben wir hier nieder liga der
irgendwie weil wieder macht er überhaupt
noch videos alter leute die irgendwas in
einer schublade suchen mit einer
taschenlampe in der hand die taschen ab
ist aber überhaupt nicht an und aus der
schublade holt er ganz ganz in die kabel
raus zitierte sache die wir haben ist
hier eine anime tänzerin die einfach in
der komischen stop motion blut tanz und
die letzte einbindung für den heutigen
tag ist jemand auf seinem fahrrad der
anscheinend ultraschall nicht
ultraschall geschwindigkeit ich dummkopf
es heißt schallgeschwindigkeit luca das
was ihr vom video meine damen und herren
wenn es euch gefallen hat und ihr
eventuell wollte das normale sachen
reagiere dann lass gerne like dazu komme
dass sehr viele kommentare von wegen er
in drei wochen hatte er verwechselte
neue produkte in einem shop was sind
denn die neuen produkte ich habe heute
meine matches sorry und auf meinem
instagram profil die teile vorgestellt
also nicht alle aber 60 prozent der
teile kommen fünf neue produkte und ich
glaube drei habe ich dort vorgestellt
also ihr könnte einfach mir dort folgen
mit heißen dort laser luca also net
instagram eigentlich nur
interessenausgleich wie auch instagram
da sind auf jeden fall schon mal ein
paar der neuen produkte und jetzt findet
ihr hier einen smiley eingebildet wenn
die da drauf den können die kosten einen
kanal abonnieren verpackt ich keine
videos mehr und ja ist einfach einfach
ein stopp eingeblendet wie gesagt erst
sechste lounge oder die neuen produkte
und hier unten ist ein weiteres video
verlinkt sogar gratis